今日はばをして勉強しない方が良いかと
んんん
んんんんん
んうん
今日はスピーカーフェです今日は
まあ普通はね言葉の勉強について話しするわけですけれども
今日はねー
言葉および英語勉強しないことにどうして勉強しない方が良いかと
それについて話ししたいと思います
僕のビデオし聞いてあれば是非
サブスクライブしてください登録してください
パンところをクリックすれば
お知らせも届けますどうして英語の勉強をやめた方がいいかと
あの
この前はネチ日本語を勉強する前は中国語を勉強したわけですよ
でどうしてもその勉強という
2つの漢字を見るときはですねー
どうしても花音
にエンチャントいう中国語の
その
単語を思い出しわけですよでにゃんちゃんっていうのはもう敷いてもやりたくないこと
をやるという事ですよ
勉強
いやいやでやるというのはもう
中国語の勉強気味なんですよ
で
ことはあのまあやはり言葉をならーというのは
実際の脳の母屋たを見るとですね
そのスキーがない好きだないものを知りてえ
いやでも習おうというのは非常に後悔低いんですよ
豪華宿だからもう
学校やめて
聖域謎の勉強もやめて
楽しいことをやらないといけないですねそれにちょっと今日は話をするつもりなんです
よ
あの子のためにもリンクという言葉の
そのウェブサイトをつくったわけですよ臨機でスキーなものを
選んで好きなな様から勉強する
その勉強勉強また勉強ですけれどもなら大
方法というのは聞いて選んで自分が面白いと思う
スキーような
ものを聞いたり読んだりすることだけでやはりあの
その言葉が頭に入りますそして
リンクのそういう図書館のある
そのレッスン休暇内容が重石君ないならばまた何処かどこからでも人気に導入して
使えることあるわけですよだからとにかく楽しく楽しいなよから勉強するのはだ
あるんですよ
あの
いろんな死刑なんですよ例えば子供
じゃあお父さんあれはお母さんがですね
子供のためにストーリーを読むでしょ
しかしもし声が
その
もしお父さんはお母さんはもうつまらないと思っている
話好きじゃないならば
赤ちゃんもそれを感じるわけですよそしてそんな
あれですよ新しい
まあ
単語やを頭はですねなかなか頭の中に0
開発されないんですよそれは実際の実験なんですよ
それよりもやはり子供にその言葉をその発見するためにはお父さんやお母さんはですね
自分が面白いと思う話
内容
積極的に楽しく読んだ方がいいです
その赤ちゃんは伊豆へちっちゃな赤ちゃんまだ何も分からないから
その音だけその言葉そのものを吸収するあの立場ですから
だから4人がを公募たあの
父様母様に自分がもう広いと思うなよ
なんかいい
この赤ちゃんのために読み上げた方が効果的だらしいんですよねっ
a
そして学校ではですねやはり
あの先生がねそれじゃあ先生が積極的でその l な英語スキーであればそれならいい
んですよ
しかし先生がそうじゃなければ非常にいい効果的ですよ
その同じあのクラスで勉強しようと思えば
もう一つはですね先生がいたすると google 教えるわけですよ
しかし脳がねルーロ
ああいう形で勉強するのは難しい
のはね自分でルールを作るわけですよ
刺激すれば楽しい面白い
そのインプットがあれば
あの
在所を聞いたらん
鉛印象がない
脳はね細いその一つ一つのそういう細かい
a
単語なる単語覚えるな難しい
だけども把握さのたくさん
一つずついろんな違ったんまのー
文章で単語が出てきたり忘れたりまた出てきた縁があったりするとですね
玉田自分でルールを作るんですよ
脳というのはそういうものなんですよ
いつも覚えてますいつもルールを作っています
だから十分な刺激を与えないといけません
けれどもその刺激は脳にとって面白い
脳にとっても楽しいでないとなかなか
入らないそれは大事なんですよだからその
楽しくというのは大切レヴールはそんなに教えなくてもいい
例えばまた赤ちゃんの話ですけれどもあーかじゃああ者シルク答弁あの
七尾あるでしょ
しかし考えてみれば安倍さんにとってばその
歩くというのはものすごい難しいわけですよバランスも取れたり
じゃあ自分の筋肉をどういうふうにその
こいね力を入れたりするのかですね
すごく複雑ですよ最初はできないんだけども
少しずつ少しずつ一つ一つの園
ハプニンが記憶にを残らないんですよ
安倍さんには誰だ
全般的にいくつかのルールきてこういうふうに動けば歩くことができると自分で頭が
ウールを作るわけですよ脳がだから別に
アルフのはこうですよと
足箱だという所の教えなくてもいいし
あの教えて守るん
赤ちゃんなのはそのルールは自分で作る
あの言葉あのそういう覚え方も同じなんですよ
いけさん
まあまず自分の母国語で話しするのから始めてね
そして外国語でもたくさんの刺激があれば
やはり頭がいくつかの rolo 最初は間違ったルール作るわけですよ赤ちゃんも
開か乗馬ルーロ
頭だあの脳がね赤ちゃんの脳がルール一生懸命作ろうとする
しかし例えば英語の場合はですね
フィリング
だけでもいろんなその同士が ed があのワークは
だ生育はセンティ多分言うかもしれませんけれども
少しずつじゃあそのルールはうまくいかないから
あーピンク明日さーっと
だからルールは必ずしも正確じゃなくてになり少しずつ少しずつ5
変化があって
もっともっと正しいそのパターンが出てくるわけですよ
もちろんあの文法のルールを読んでもいいんですよ
選んでもし十分すでにたくさんそういう経験があるんだ
ちょっと自分がこう思ったルールはやそうじゃないとこうだというような程度でルール
を見てもいいけれども
by あっても忘れるしかしそういう覚えても忘れたりまた脳が自動的にいろんな
ルールも知らいてその中からまずます
正しいあの
表現の仕方が出てください
8方もそうですね発音を好きな港へ
楽しい声
僕中国語を勉強した時にそういうシェアんちゃんというお互いにその
を笑い話をやっている人たちの仮説体パターつは聞いた楽しいからか楽しいから非常に
その発音するにも
役に立ちました
商用意味ではですね途中の教科書
それは英語であろうカラー
もう日本語であろうがまあ韓国を中国皆つまらない声
座らないあのナレーターが
ロー今するわけでしょそれは6にそれよりも自分のスキーな声好きななよ
それを真似をすれば発音もいい良くなる
だからその勉強というのはね
3エンチャンっていうのはもういいやでもという勉強のやめて楽しく習いましょう
そういう意味で僕のビデオも僕はその言葉の勉強
のどのテーマは大好きだからいつも
もスキーだからその自分が好きだという言葉ね
多分私のそういう話の中にも現れていると思うんですよ
だからあの時分皆さんのそれぞれのその英語の勉強にも役に立ちても
だから
僕の今の youtube チャームでも好きな billion 英語のビデオ
ぜひあの聞いてくださいでしょそして場合によってはそれを
あのー
だいたい2位のは当初館英語のと時間にそれがあるわけですから
しょるそこまあこういう中で見てもいいし
リンクに導入してもいいし r がウィングの塔周辺です探してもいいけれどもぜひ
推薦しますじゃ楽しく勉強まあ池ザ
楽しく覚えましょうっていうことですねはいどうもじゃあサイバー
んん
うん
12分
1分
[音楽]